los cubanos ya pueden disfrutar de las
terrazas de los restaurantes de nuevo
por sorpresa el jueves el gobierno
cubano anunció la reapertura en un
intento por apoyar su maltrecha economía
y el turismo que se reactivará en
noviembre hay condiciones para ir dando
paso gradual en una apertura reapertura
de estos servicios presencial y también
y de alguna manera bueno restableciendo
también socialmente lo que lo que hemos
perdido en todos estos meses los bares y
restaurantes de cuba que ahora
trabajarán con el 50 por ciento de
software o llevaban meses cerrados
tiempo en el que los ciudadanos de la
habana no habían podido disfrutar de
este tipo de servicios presenciales por
eso la noticia fue acogida con ilusión
en medio de la crisis económica nosotros
estamos contenta claro que ha cerrado
nos aliamos compartíamos las amistades
empezamos la universidad de nuevo es
algo que no nos apasiona mucho además de
la recesión financiera como enfrenta un
fuerte rebrote de casos desde hace dos
meses con una de las tasas de contagios
por 100.000 habitantes más altas del
mundo
por eso el país sigue trazando tácticas
para frenar el cobe 19 como la
vacunación para aquellos que superaron
la enfermedad una decisión avalada
científicamente
la isla espera tener el 90 por ciento de
la población inmunizada para noviembre